okay so here are my ideas and we know
that eva is gone
and i'm trying we all agreed we promised
ila we would not be getting cancelled
while she was gone yes we did
so i've compiled an extensive list of
ideas
that are funny wholesome and will not
get us cancelled
i say us but me yeah and so
so fantastic that sounds great so
reacting to bts new music video
let's give our full unfiltered reaction
to bts's new music video
no no vetoed why dan i like it it
doesn't matter
dark souls play through no commentary oh
that's not really accountable offense
it's a bad idea
okay oh drive the gatsby into a
load-bearing
beam one of these and see if we can
collapse the building
absolutely no that's ethan ethan no
no no do not
do this ethan no no no ethan ethan ethan
you have good insurance maybe a
liability
move out to the woods buy a cabin swear
off technology
and talk about the industrial revolution
and its consequences
vis-a-vis become a terrorist
how is that content if you have no
technology you can't shoot that what is
that idea
you think kleinzinski just yeah
okay not a good idea i get it so buying
everything
on every fast food menu challenge and
seeing how much weight i can gain
before ila comes home i think that's a
[ __ ] great idea thank you
that's a great idea zach likes it
dan check this out 3057 double quarter
powder
with cheese meals 30 dollars we see if
we can finish it
to order here yeah we could do that's
like what like uh eight thousand a piece
ela is not gonna like that like thirty
thousand dollars in mcdonald's
no no everyone else no i'm in man okay
guys this one is
you're gonna love it's super safe
wholesome and fun black out drunk
on a live stream don't react hear the
second part
and talk about complex racial issues in
america
no i do love it i'm into it okay well
fine let's talk about trans athletes
you know in sports
you are not equipped for that discussion
no no no no
no no too much even zach's saying no
yeah okay let's see how many people we
can defame
in one episode the goal is to see how
many defamation lawsuits
i can generate from one episode of the
podcast so it'd be
saying stuff like keemstar
oh euthanize ian we'll put you to death
no we'll euthanize ian no i mean we do
have the robot
yeah we have sam can we euthanize ian
absolutely not
oh she does like you know ian likes to
die
i'm afraid you might like the idea do i
get a bonus
sure thank you whatever you want after
you're dead okay
catholic church all the scandals of the
catholic church
you know what i'm saying there's a lot
unpacked there
i know exactly what you're saying boy
scouts no
country themed episode i do cut my
country voice for an entire episode oh
my god
[Music]
uh youtube boxing matches are super
popular right now
here's someone i feel like would
generate a lot of hype and who would be
a good challenge for me
ryan toys reviews boxing match he's a
child he's a kid
he's a little child is he five oh he's
got a huge [ __ ]
yeah i mean what is this idea for views
why i just feel
bad oh
start an h3 snapchat
to connect with our younger fans
under eight you have a lot of people
under 18 on snapchat those are really
good people
to watch the show i'll say hey i'll go
to people under age and say hey
add me on snapchat see what happens okay
this one might actually be an
international crime
but my picture to you hiring chinese
hackers to ddos
trailer is that a crime no like to
shut down the service yeah no that's
definitely a crime it is yeah
i feel like it's gonna shut down on its
own so right that's fair
okay ryan kavanagh pinata slash burning
and effigy is that too far
like build of life like size model of
ryan cavanagh and
wood straw set it on fire it's like five
steps too far
zach likes it of course
dude you guys are this is the top you
guys are a tough crowd i mean this is
okay go to japan
suicide forest go into the suicide
forest
make a vlog see what happens you don't
know what you find there
yeah we know you do know what you find
there well yeah maybe that's the point
dude you guys have got to toss me a bone
here okay
okay fine being wholesome exercising and
eating healthy the entire time while
ela's gone
to surprise her when she gets here oh
that sounds really nice
okay we're gonna befriend tati
westbrooks gain her trust
become friends with her you know have
her over the house
meet her husband you know we're good
friends and then when she least expects
it promote
sugar bear hair vitamins boom
let's go come on that didn't end well
come on
burning down my house for insurance
money
what eight eight part docu-series on
shane
to to give him a redemption arc
uh making fupa coin real pull the rug
make a bunch of money
i'm into that one yeah i mean you guys
all benefit from that
oh make a puzzle with a qr code set make
sell it
and uh nobody wins but me uh
that is a scam that's you're describing
a scam but a smart business move
okay so i don't know what's i don't know
what you guys don't like about the like
getting drunk in the race
okay i mean i really think that the
catholic church one has legs and
you wanted to euthanize me
so does this mean you guys don't like my
ideas because you know this sucks
there are some legs here no i mean
definition speedrun definitely
is interesting i mean nobody's ever done
that before where no
you can get defended as much as possible
i mean as long as we do have ian's
permission we can euthanize him
nope you got a show to do all right
that's as far as we can go
guys
don't need help hate my ideas i got good
ideas
coming ideas man ah
i don't need them to do the show i'm
gonna do about
i'm gonna do this show by myself
i can't believe you guys really taped me
up like that i mean i didn't deserve
that
you you absolutely needed it i mean dang
it's really hard not to get cancelled
without eli here literally every one of
my ideas was horrible
and cancelable you believe that
yeah i do off the rails come on
let's go
that sound bite ends a little abruptly
zach
i need to fade it out today's episode is
sponsored by canva
credit karma money me und stamps.com and
shady raise and yes ryan kavanagh i do
know you're counting our sponsors we
have five
i know you are not going to get any of
that money
speaking of ryan kavanagh friend of the
show
we made this compar you know first of
all ryan cavanaugh the guy who's suing
me from trailer
uh infringing my my first amendment
right
we just crunched the numbers you know
how there's a celebrity lookalikes ryan
your celeb
your celebrity look alike is harvey
weinstein
i'm just saying that you guys we've been
having a debate
does ryan cavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein a lot of you guys have been
saying
you don't see the resemblance i do not
it's it's
it's a big stretch i'm sorry it's not
show it or
the more i see him the more i start to
see it look at the resemblance
he totally [ __ ] does middle age white
guys
it says how dare you i'm just
i mean i'm sorry i don't know i just
don't be clear he looks closer than any
of us look
or that's very true of all of us were to
stand next to harvey weinstein
oh please the you think i have
resemblance to harvey weinstein get out
of here
i see it in his forehead his eyes his
beard his beard his whole face
on his face also like his profession i
mean he's a big time
movie producer or he was before he
bankrupted his company
right yeah which i i believe the
weinstein company is having some
financial issues as well so there is a
thank you dan for very different reasons
for very different reasons yes
we love dan i'm not accusing ryan
cavanaugh the guy who's suing me from
chiller of
sexual impropriety i just think they
look similar that's all
you know just make that clear
um oh you know what we have to do
an ad read at the top of the show so
bear with us here one sec because we got
shady rays look at these sunglasses
so hot so stylish let me tell you about
shady rays
while i'm doing that why don't you go
show off your specs we are all hooked up
with shady rays
here's the deal with shady rays high
quality shades
for that are just straight up less
expensive than the name brands because
they own the distribution they have
put it online they have mastered the
means of production you know they've got
one of the best warranties
in the sunglass industry if you lose
or break it boom they're going to
replace it for you
no questions asked does that wow that's
unbelievable
and you know what else they do they
donate 10 meals to fight hunger in
america with every order
come on shady raise
they start at just 48 bucks they have a
bunch of fantastic styles
and you're just gonna be getting that
super high end quality for a fraction of
the price with the craziest warranty
and they're going to be donating money
to hungry people in america so it pretty
much is a perfect trifecta
exclusive for our listeners shady razors
running their deepest deal of the season
50
off all shades excuse me
let me put these back on use code h50
for 50 off any pair of sunglasses at
shadyraise.com
you can get a premium polarized pair of
shades for as low as 28
with the code h50 redeemable
only at shadyraise.com where you can
find all their newest
and best shades thank you shady rays oh
that's hot
i would continue to wear these but we're
inside
all right all right all right thank you
uh man so this has been a weird week for
me
obligatory we have a fantastic episode
today
just throw that out there it's true it's
true
coffeezilla the guy who's been putting
together this whole investigation
into the um crypto schemes being run by
faze and all these guys
fantastic so we're gonna talk to him
about it logan paul one of our big
stories about how logan paul
has perpetuated such a
huge crypto scam it's on the level of
like pro syndicate and t martin cs go
lottery
because he he he owns this he made it
and he's pretending like he doesn't know
what it is allegedly but the evidence is
clearly there
correct yeah anyway i'm a strawberry
uh thank you logan uh
this has now been when did eli leave
this has been like you know
she left on sunday and it's uh what
[ __ ] day is it
it's wednesday it's wednesday my dude
not even close to a week it feels like
it's been forever
it's so weird being in the house without
elan theodore you know it's dominated my
life it's like you come home
it's theodore time and it's so
freaking quiet you know so quiet
you got a little spook magoot no not
spook no i haven't been spooked magoof
just feeling lonely and bored
when i'm not working i could come over
we play some video games or i'm not that
desperate oh
damn thank you though for offering give
it a few more days
maybe yeah in a few days i'll be calling
ab to come and
keep me company
[Music]
not that i wouldn't want to hang out
with you it's just there is a there is a
certain
you know boss employee
if you fire me we can hang out right
what kind of logic is that it's like the
office romance where it's like you
if you fire me we can be together right
just think about it i like you as an
employee
okay thank you not a lover an employer
ian i would fire to hang out with ian do
you want me to fire you so we can be
friends
i mean i appreciate that thank you
so is that a no or yes i'll keep my job
keep the jump let's keep it
professionally let's keep it yeah
okay but anyway it's been so quiet you
know
you think that ila thought i'd be having
so much fun at home she's like oh he's
gonna play video games and watch anime
i sit there because i've been working a
lot so i'm busy all day
work till like eight or nine o'clock and
i sit down
there's nothing to watch on the tv
there's nobody to talk to last night i
tried to order a pizza
the weirdest the [ __ ] i swear to god
bro
postmates scammed me
maybe not postmates but the driver
itself tell me if this guy
tell me if you ever heard of anything
like this it was so [ __ ] up
it's probably a good thing because i
ordered a big-ass pizza for myself like
a big [ __ ] like a 60
pizza not good but anyway
ela don't listen to this
probably do that tonight but don't
so the post so i ordered this pizza it
says it's going to arrive
in like an hour and a half i guess
because it's busy so then all of a
sudden i'm watching the driver they say
they picked up the pizza
it's like a 30 minute drive then all of
a sudden i live in a guarded community
so they have to go to the guard
to get permission to enter the community
but then all of a sudden on the app it
shows the car
is magically like an hour ahead of
schedule
in front of my house and i don't know if
you guys have seen this but it gives
like an eight minute warning
if you don't contact your driver i had
never seen that the driver texted me he
says i can't find your door
and i says the door is like it's not
hidden it's
very obvious it's so obvious where the
front door is
so i go this is so weird you know and
the minute he sends the i'm at your
front door
he starts this eight minute timer and it
says if you don't contact your driver
within
uh eight minutes then you're not going
to be refunded for your order
so i'm tech so i'm texting him
i'm like i'm outside i don't see you on
the on the postmates map it shows that
the driver is right in front of my house
so i'm standing there there's no car i
called the gate
i said did anyone enter with food and
they say nobody's no nobody's come into
the community and they would know
so this driver mysteriously shows up in
front of my house an hour early
says i can't find the door on the map it
shows the cars right in front of my
house
and i'm going where are you where are
you where are you i'm in front i don't
see you i don't think you're here
and then all he ever says is i can't
find your door
the eight minutes expire and then he
[ __ ] disappears
in reality you guys got scammed
i feel like there's some weird and then
the driver itself
only had like 50 15 deliveries he didn't
have a profile picture
i felt like this is some weird scheme
that people are running
as like fake postmates drivers
uh that is very strange i have a
conspiracy theory
go ahead maybe ela tipped off the guards
she's like if you see any [ __ ] pizza
guys come through here
you turn their ass around and why do you
say i can't see your door
huh he said i can't find your door
because the guard related the message to
the pizza man
it's a deep conspiracy between ela the
driver and the guard yes
and the pizza place correct they're all
in on it
the earth is flat we've never been to
the moon
i i've never had a good postmates
experience i know
so i i would believe that something
would
happen like this through that app um
i've just i've never
had a good experience with them you know
what i'm not gonna say that i do have
plenty of good
postmates experiences but this one i
have a lot of bad ones recently though
zack so i do co-sign but
this one was so weird i felt like
someone
is doing something super shady here
and i don't like it so that's my story
fascinating stuff here guys fascinating
i found it really fascinating anyway
don't you think these two look alike
i mean harvey's got a little extra
weight i think that's the only
difference
like if if ryan gained maybe like 50
pounds
there'd be red hair
well harvey has kind of reddish like
light hair too
yes no yes no
how do you not see it it's the same
person
um coffeezilla's gonna be calling in in
30 minutes that's gonna be fun
should you ask coffeezilla about the
pizza scam you think
he's kind of like the scamp buster guy
this little deep cut
seems like it was a mute problem
user air at this point
that's so odd that happened though i've
never uh no meaning i've never
encountered anything like
so i was hoping maybe one someone else
out there has that experience because
i'm telling you
something was fishy in that whole
[ __ ] thing yo speaking of
uh fishy face blanks
he was having some fishy issues with
crypto this is a deep cut since we've
been goofing on this guy
um here he is apparently he's a pro
gamer they walk into a game stop
expecting everybody to bow before them
excuse me
it's the coke watch this is so good
phase blanks
cruising in a mall remember malls guys
yeah right game stop this is a pro gamer
everybody bow before me faze up
look at this [ __ ] guy he actually
says phase up yeah they say it a bunch
hands up dark souls 2 wow that was a
long time ago
oh man shirt down he goes
why would they even post that like that
clearly
did not go like as if they what they
wanted
i mean maybe they were just goofing
maybe phase up
yo
that's the guy that's infinitely more
successful than you ethan
so maybe you should have a little more
respect i'm infinitely smarter and more
successful than you
i'm infinitely smarter than you and um
infinitely more successful than you
yeah as proven by this clip you can see
you can see the respect and success
just by recognition alone
yeah call of duty athletes
i think he's [ __ ] stupid
i feel like if faze banks you know what
i wish he was doing instead of um
competing in esports uh cooking beer
at a monastery making loggers at a
monastery like monks
right you're making friars to brother
banks
yeah brother banks okay brother banks
would be great at cooking
or brewing uh beers and lagers
[Music]
in a monastery back in like the 1500s
you drank beer you would brew i think
the fact you said cooking
beer kind of threw you off there yeah
yeah brewing beer this is where this is
bank's true calling
i imagine banks on a horse drawn
buggy with barrels in the back
cloak spreading love and joy via the
they got one of the best brews in the
whole damn county
and having some beers with friends
so i saw some comments that evidently um
brother banks has an origin beyond the
the monk meme oh for real what is it
yeah
i can't recall what it was but it i mean
it's still it still works
yes it's evolved we've taken it to the
next level
but yeah apparently it predated his uh
his bald spot revelation
so it seems like it was just meant to be
yeah yeah exactly
those two in all aspects no such thing
as a coincidence oh this is so good you
guys a
rice gum spotify got hacked
whatever is going on on ricegum spotify
to begin with i don't [ __ ] know
but anyway here is a new
hit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you such a [ __ ] kind of a bop
[Laughter]
and before we move on of course you know
uh we've been following just for my own
you know as a social media influencer
is my duty to follow the happenings of
social media platforms trailer being one
of them
yes and we have
some new triller reviews to report on
whoever left these i don't know it's not
going well for them lately i've noticed
they've actually been getting i've
noticed a lot of one-star reviews
which i think means people are just
generally having bad experiences with
the app instead of good
instead of good experiences which would
generate a five star generally when i
use an app and i like it i i would i
would give it a high rating like a four
maybe even maybe even a five yeah uh i
mean i didn't like it that's why i left
this one star review
of trailer oh right right right i forgot
we said triller using trailer has been
one of the worst experiences of my life
so that was by me
one star you guys share your own
experiences uh who have used it here we
go
i don't know if this is one of you guys
just you know
i'll read this i've been using this app
for a while hoping that one day i could
serve as a viable social media platform
but due to this apps mismanagement and
horrible communications with this
creator
of which kevin hart is not included
right because they promised kevin hart
was on the app he's not i came to the
conclusion that i had to delete the app
for my own well-being
so my truck one day i wanted to research
why this app was so horrifically
mismanaged
a quick google search of trailers ceo
ryan cavanaugh who i believe bears a
striking resemblance to harvey weinstein
see i told him
what the hell i noticed that i guess you
aren't the only one i
i don't see it resulted in an article
from
respected publication variety as i was
reading about ryan cavanaugh's
ex-partner accusing him of running a
ponzi scheme in the variety article
i drove my ford f-150 into a community
pool destroying fencing
a lifeguard stand and the pool siding oh
no i feel like that's more your fault
than ryan kavanaugh's ball
our trailers fall yeah you cannot put
that on that's not a fair
uh unfair that's not a fair route i've
been charged with felony destruction of
property and i'm facing up to five years
in prison
i feel ryan kavanaugh is responsible but
i am unsure if he could even pay
any amount of my bail as triller is like
hemorrhaging money well
everything is true except i really doubt
that that's ryan
kavanaugh's fault you shouldn't have
been looking at your phone while driving
yo trailer my thing's flipped
oh this one got a two star my favorite
part about this app is that there's so
much potential
since no one uses it it's very easy to
rise to the top oh that's a good point
i feel like i can hear an echo when i
post i've never seen an app before with
so little engagement or interesting
content
it's like a sandbox with no sand so feel
free to fill it with whatever you want
interesting that's a really good review
two stars
they're saying listen there's nothing
here now
it's a blank slate you know yeah
although
you can go anywhere from there if you
rise to the top and there's nobody to
watch you i don't know how good that is
two-star though big big fish in a small
pond you know what i mean
like you gotta you gotta find your niche
ugh it's so awkward
[Music]
oh this one's a five star just to be
fair my app
five stars cool nice review
wait is that ryan did ryan leave that
they say it's his app
my app oh my god do you think that was
right that might have been ryan it's my
app
five star i mean i don't think that's a
fair review as much as i thought thought
that first
one star wasn't fair yeah it seems like
self-dealing to review your
own app but also it's like that's not a
fair my app i mean what the hell does
that mean
of course you like it it's your app
something this one said they made them
haunted
one star interesting i don't know just
something about it every time i try to
use it i get the feeling that someone is
watching me it's not such a scary
feeling
but more of an overwhelmingly sad one
it's suffocating
just like the user interface to be
honest the last times i opened the app
actually ended up having nightmares wow
and the weird thing is that they were
all exactly the same i would get caught
up in a ponzi scheme
[Music]
bad and i would have to do a lot of bad
things to get myself
out the nightmares always end the same
way with me dying bankrupt alone
sad that is horrific wow
holy [ __ ] uninstall
uninstall my friend because that yeah
that sounds cursed
anyway i think a very sick person may
have trapped their soul in this app
and i recommend avoiding it one star
whoa that one might be worth
uh framing that's a really good one
that's definitely one to one star
you know so that those are really good
yeah is there any other one you
recommend reading they're pretty long
ian
are you thinking in curated these i
don't know i'm sure that's fine
yeah that one was really good i'm glad i
read that one
oh you know i have to say there's been a
lot of great kavanaugh memes on the
subreddit
ryan cavanaugh owner of triller the guy
who's suing me and infringing on my
first
amendment right of speech
so this is more of an energetically
aligned meme
so here's ryan kevin on the middle who
looks like harvey weinstein which we've
established here
according to some according to some
and then the other thing is that he's
energetically aligned with kevin spacey
disgraced actor
because kevin spacey was considering
buying
relativity media after ryan cavanaugh
bankrupted it yeah i
and i looked into it more it was kind of
confusing because i guess at some point
he was involved
maybe not buying oh he was like on the
board of the directors or something
yeah i forget the exact thing super
super interestingly involved
but the point of this meme is just to
show that they are energetically aligned
of course not saying that brian
cavanaugh has committed any sexual
crimes i mean how would i know that
yeah i i'm not saying he didn't i'm just
saying that we don't have evidence to
support one way or the other how can you
tell that they're energetically aligned
from this not not to hate on the person
who created this but
oh i just explained it there's no such
thing as the course there's no such
thing as a coincidence
all right no there's no evidence that
ryan has done asexual crimes i don't
want to no definitely not
yeah don't want to say that false
best friends make the good times better
and the hard times
easier of course just i think what the
point of this is that
they have a lot in common in terms of
being like their occupation the fact
that they're both going through
bankruptcies
stuff like that and is this a real photo
of them together that i don't actually
know
cam uh cam made this one cam was there
were they actually in a photo together
oh he's he's editing right now he's he's
deep
undercover i need to know somebody ask
him is harvey weinstein in uh
ryan kavanaugh picture are they uh is
that a real photo or no
he's just that no it's not a real photo
they've never this is not a real photo
no you got us but i do feel like they
would make best friends because they
have so much in common
personally oh here's orion
professionally not personally actually
i say what you said they personally have
a lot in common i think it's more fair
to say they professionally have a lot of
comment
i just think they have a lot in common
one way or the other okay just
i want to be very clear on what the
comparison here is
i mean yeah the fact that they were both
big producers in hollywood
yeah both going through bankruptcies
that's also part of their professional
life okay well that's a matter of
opinion so that's okay
they probably have a lot of the same
friends so personal you know
um okay you know they have the same
friends
come on oh here's a picture of ryan
cavanaugh
posing with a picture of ryan cavanaugh
above the variety article
oh no yeah did i realize ryan kavanaugh
accused my ex-partner of running a ponzi
scheme it's him posing with the variety
article
crazy there's no such thing as a
coincidence oh
you must have not read that okay now
this one is a game so you guys help me
oh no ryan kevin has lost his face and
need your help so you guys tell me
which number fits here it's kind of hard
to tell
this is harvey weinstein i know that oh
is it
nice welcome to put that face
on ryan kavanagh today we've got six
choices
we have to decide which number goes on
the face
if you win you don't get sued for
defamation that's right
so i'm trying to sort these out okay
number four
that's that's our boy that would be
eight off
um uh and number six that appears to be
phase blanks right that would be phase
blanks i agree
okay and number two obviously is our our
good friend friend of the show keemstar
you are a [ __ ] hypocrite yeah but
who's number five that's the one that's
kind of
it kind of looks like maybe bolsonaro
maybe that's funny you know he's a
shitty dude whoever it is
yeah okay so based on okay so if you
show behind me
uh ian i'm pretty sure i've seen this
photo a lot
right i know it's not harvey it's not
harvey i think it's this guy
right i think that's number three am i
right
we actually don't yeah number three we
have a winner we have a winner
number four does look a lot like him
though
let's i was thinking about choosing
number four that is a black and white
photo
i don't know why he would be
photographed in black and white
right that's adolf hitler not ryan
kavanagh right
oh i got two and four confused i'm sorry
what's the next one
you know i almost put number one i
almost put number one
you got two and four confused are you
duck yeah
whatever yeah i almost put number one
which would have been
um harvey weinstein but i was like oh i
think it's three
yeah i believe it's three here's another
one
come closer spongebob mabe did you know
did you know that ryan kavanaugh was
accused by his ex-partner of running a
ponzi scheme
that's me on my deathbed right
fantastic stuff trailer your thing is
flipped
yo trailer my thing's flip of course
i'll call back to noah back who
is being paid to use the app and still
be making tick tocks bitching about it
so that's fantastic oh it's so
awkward we think he's being paid do we
know that oh please
but do we know that i mean have i seen
his bank statements
yes yes i've audited it at all
no i don't know i haven't seen the bank
i'm pretty sure whatever you know he is
look it up do your own research
i'm pretty sure there's articles about
it and stuff but well i know that they
paid influencers to post on there
but well they wrote them in the freaking
description of the app
they know back serves as an advisor and
has equity
share thank you fact checkers
maybe thank you i just don't wanna we
gotta
you love that i think it's on the
advisory board and he's like this app is
so [ __ ]
that this guy can make a bunch of money
if it succeeded that's how he was giving
his feedback
and he's like yo trailer
my thing is flipped oh this is star wars
meme
did you ever hear the tragedy of ryan
kavanagh he was accused by his
ex-partner of running a ponzi scheme
that is a tragedy that's a really good
anecdote from the star wars universe
yeah even the sith lord knows about the
ponzi scheme
emperor palpatine emperor palpatine has
even read the variety article
darth kavanagh oh here's this classic
meme any business
and then ryan goes is this something i
can bankrupt
well he's already bankrupted one big
business we're about to find out if he
can make it two with trailer
my bet is yes who is better
ryan cavanaugh or this happy monkey
let's see let's do a comparison i mean
that's this is a really uh compelling uh
comparison
okay ryan cavanaugh has bankrupted a
business
happy monkey has not bankrupted a
business
cool point for the monkey yep accused of
running a ponzi scheme ryan cavanaugh
happy monkey not accused of running a
ponzi scheme
that we know of right that we know of
that's fair to
say for the monkey at least he hasn't
been accused of it
in open court by an ex-business partner
no no no right the monkey has not
we can confidently say that uh ryan
cavanaugh
he has been said to resemble harvey
weinstein
by me by you and many others let's be
honest
uh this monkey has not been said to
resemble harvey weinstein
that is interesting uh ryan kavanagh
hated by many
who i don't know if i can gauge that i
mean i'm sure that the people like he
i've read the bankruptcy filings and he
screwed over a lot of people didn't get
paid so i guess that's fair to say
we'll dive more into the bankruptcy
stuff next week we got a big whole
episode
on uh ryan cavanaugh that's gonna be
freaking amazing
um but yeah i think it's i think that's
fair to assume because of the bankruptcy
he's hated by many
and this happy monkey is loved by many
because he's a happy monkey
i love him i love him yeah
i also i do not like ryan kavanagh
personally
um ryan cavett does not own any bananas
can we prove that
that's unprovable yeah same with the
monkey owns many bananas we can't
we can't prove that although we can't
prove that ryan cavanagh does own
triller
and the happy monkey does not own
triller so in conclusion the happy
monkey wins
love the monkey we love the monkey don't
we folks
okay you tell me there's no resemblance
here remember harvey weinstein this is
him now feel old yet
that is that could be the same person
dude it totally could be stop it dan
i disagree oh this is ryan kevin on
keemstar uh
uh flirting about me in class
probably talking all kinds of trash
about me behind my back
okay so this is interesting cocaine this
is your eyes on cocaine
marijuana beer ponzi
now let me just clarify he was accused
by his ex-partner running a ponzi
you know so that's yeah but ponzi wow
that's funny
this is just them together again
animorphs ryan kavanagh learns about
fraud
man you guys been heavily at work here
that's pretty good
all right listen douchebag apparently
people think we look alike personally i
don't see it
holy [ __ ] no yeah i see that we got the
same eyes same gnomes same lips that's
what i'm saying
yeah and there's one thing that cameron
made that i think is worth sharing
um um cameron made this which i
i think if anything really proves how
much they do look alike so dan you watch
this and you tell me
so this is this is um
you guys watch this and tell me what you
think
there's harvey weinstein does ryan
cavanaugh or wait is that right kavanagh
and is that harvey weinstein it's really
hard to tell the difference between the
two i feel like i can tell the
difference
i don't know i can't tell the difference
[Music]
i really can't yeah so that was that was
okay that's right kavanaugh that's
harvey weinstein no
you you got it backwards oh see i
confused them all right
on their physical appearance understood
uh we got to go to break
already yes having way too much fun yeah
bro i still have more kevin on memes
we'll have to come back to it
we're actually we're way over oh [ __ ]
okay let's go do throw to a break we'll
be right back take a short break
thank you thank you rudy
credit karma money credit karma has
always been there to help you make
better financial decisions and now they
want to help you even more with credit
karma money spend account you can be
rewarded
for good money habits credit card money
is a brand new checking account
where you can win cash reimbursements
just for making
purchases now let me tell you why this
is revolutionary you shouldn't only get
rewards for credit cards but credit
karma money with those debit cards
coming in with those rewards
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase reimbursements on items
of up
to five thousand dollars just pay with
your debit card and if you win you'll be
notified on the spot
and your instant karma cash will be
added back to your spend account
credit karma money has already given
away over three million dollars in
instant karma over 50
000 credit karma members and counting
open your fdic insured
spend account for free there's no
minimum balance requirements
no overdraft fees and free withdrawals
from a network of over 50 000 atms and
get this
when you between july 1st and july 23rd
when you make a purchase you'll
automatically be entered to win
1 million dollars credit karma money
progress starts here right now visit
creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning
instant karma go to creditkarma.com one
money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's
creditkarma.com
when money credit uh instant karma is
sponsored by credit karma no purchase is
necessary exclusions and terms apply
c rules banking services provided by mbb
bank incorporated member fdic maximum
balance and transfer limits
apply save bon voyage
to your old torn up mangled underwear
that's been sitting in your drawer
since fifth grade be honest i know
they're there
because comfort starts now with me
undies
okay me undies is soft luxurious game
changing underwear
you know we've been all shopping bottom
of the barrel
undies for too long we got to treat
ourselves we're adults now we got to
take care of ourselves that's what
mandy's all about
it fits perfectly it breathes it's soft
it's an underwear revolution
and with me on these memberships you're
never gonna run out of undies or worry
about skipping laundry day again
each month replenish your basics and
build your collection with styles that
are
anything but basic styles that let you
be true version of yourself
right down to your core and your
genitals
no pressure you can always skip a month
if you don't want to plus enjoy
discounting prices controlled shipping
and exclusive early access love your bot
and get the membership
meanders has a great offer for our
listeners for any first time purchase
you get 15
off and free shipping mandy's also has
their problem free philosophy if you're
not satisfied with any product for any
reason
they'll refund it or exchange it no
caveats no questions
so to get fifteen percent off your first
order and free shipping go to
meundies.com
h3 that's meundies.com you guys are not
gonna regret this go to their website
check out all the fun prints and styles
check it out you guys can have a lot of
fun with that i promise mendes.com
h3 listen stamps is a fact of life
you're gonna mail stuff
why not do it with stamps.com it's more
convenient
it's cheaper it's better you do it from
home i love stamps don't even get me
started man i love stamps
stamps.com saves businesses thousands of
hours and tons
of money every year stamps.com brings
the same us postal and ups servings
shipping services right to your computer
they make it easy for small businesses
to mail and ship
without needing to take a trip to the
post office print official us posts and
shipping labels 24 7 without having to
leave your desk
or buy any fancy equipment all you need
is your computer
and a standard printer once your mail is
ready just schedule a pickup or drop it
off it's that simple guys stamps.com
it's a no-brainer saving nearly 1
million small business owners like you
time
and money time and money people they
offer deals you can't get anywhere else
like up to 40 off usps and up to 66
off ups shipping rates excuse me
and with their switch and save feature
you can quickly compare carriers to find
the best rates every time
so stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with promo code h3
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long term commitment or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in h3 that's
stamps.com
promo code h3 stamps.com never go to the
post office again
canva pro is the easy to use design
platform that has everything you need
to design like a pro whether you're a
professional designer or just getting
started canva pro can help boost you
and your team's productivity and
creativity it's quick easy affordable
way to design
whatever you need no matter what you're
creating and sharing canva pro has
everything you need in one place
including a collection of over 75
million premium
photos videos audio and graphics plus
canva pro
comes with time saving tools that
simplify and speed up the creative
process
you get all you get all you need
in one place it's canva pro baby
canva pro subscription this is what i
love about campbell pros that
when you look at some of the alternative
uh photo editing services they're really
complicated
super expensive not user friendly it
takes like a kind of like a lifetime to
effectively use some of these software's
out there canva pro is made to be used
right it's usability but still with that
advanced
level ability to edit
photos create templates you know doing
everything you would want to do
with that photo editing software but
just so much easier to get in the door
and start using it that's what i love
about canva pro
there's no idea too big or too small for
canva pro
you know if you are uh a student
you're on a marketing team you're
running a business you're just a crafty
mom
i mean it's really the go-to photo
software i would recommend it to anyone
who's not trying to spend their life
dedicated to learning this other
software that's way more expensive
not saying names but you know exactly
what i'm [ __ ] talking about canva pro
designed like a pro with canva pro right
now
you can get a free 45-day extended trial
when you use my promo code
just go to canva.me
h3 to get your free 45-day extended
trial that's
c a n v a dot me m e
slash h3 that's canva dot me slash h3
welcome back everybody uh to the the
ryan kavanagh accused by ex-partner of
running a
ponzi scheme podcast we've replaced
h3 with the variety article and to be
fair i mean we do
you know
[Applause]
it's interesting description that's all
i'll say we do talk
about ryan a decent amount on this
podcast yes he's come up a few times
uh the one i'm gonna close the book on
this thing sorry to keep uh you know
going on but there was one funny
development with ryan
um he was recently we caught him buying
followers on instagram
pretty awesome huh allegedly oh this now
come on there's no allegedly this is a
[ __ ]
well uh oh
okay let's just say allegedly but you
guys decide nicki minaj posts
almost 3 million likes by the way
giveaway time
i love how she makes it seem like she's
just being this generous soul giving
away and not being paid by this
echelon it's so stupid giveaway time
i'm giving out iced diamond barbie
chains
three computers to get your education on
jerk off on more like who gets educated
on computers for porn
literally exclusively four bags
so here's what it says in the
description
to enter it simple follow echelon
giveaways
and everyone they are following right
now okay
then we go we go on over to echelon
here's echelon who's uh restoried
follow everyone we are following for a
chance to win who does echelon follow 99
people one of which
ryan cavanaugh
boom so excellent giveaways is literally
didn't we have here
this is a description a mission
statement from their website by the way
uh just in case you had any doubt left
this is literally their description of
what they do this is the biggest scheme
like
you know that buying followers doesn't
do [ __ ] like it's just
it's so pointless i guess maybe for
someone like ryan cavanaugh just looks
good
i guess followers yeah even though his
engagement is like
zero he has like he gets like 300 likes
on his post
and just having it inflated i mean yeah
maybe if you're going into a deal with
somebody
you're like oh i have this many
followers they think that you're more
popular than you are yeah but if you
know anything about social media you
would go to the post and be like this
guy has 300
likes but like a million million
followers right yeah nothing's not
adding up here kind of a tell
here's echelon they say looking to grow
your brand or business organically
oh yeah nothing more organic than a
giveaway
look no further here at echelon we
specialize in hosting influencer
giveaways these giveaways are intended
to help your
brand tap into an audience you may not
otherwise reach
with help of a-list celebrities nicki
minaj and their millions of followers we
had amazing success in growing our
sponsors social media platforms et
cetera et cetera
so yeah he paid them to get followers on
instagram
and it's i would say a little
embarrassing to get caught doing that
so ryan kavanaugh is buying instagram
followers via echelon giveaways
allegedly allegedly what kind of guy
would do that he's just so insecure
i mean he owns a social media company
and so
maybe to him it's like if i am not
popular on social media then i'm uh you
know i'm a fraud
um nothing says
getting a rant a bunch of random people
who don't know me to follow me
a guy with a billion dollars and uh no
respect
hmm wow he's got all the money and none
of the respect
the shade i want to be around the yeah
exactly
do you think it's do you think people
don't respect him because they mistake
him for
harvey weinstein sometimes that maybe i
wasn't
trying to i am i just do not feel that
that is the thing they go oh my god
that's harvey weinstein
i
it looks like him but maybe that's not
him it is a stretch that anyone would
make that mistake
i don't know anyway shout out i don't
know if that's against
instagram terms of service either i
don't think you're supposed to buy
followers but hey what can you do
oh i'm supposed to make this disclaimer
okay
so okay guys this is important
disclaimer regarding
the ponzi scheme thing so everybody
listen up we want to be fair we want to
tell the whole picture
and we want to be objective as possible
so when it comes to the ponzi scheme
his partner ex-partner who accused him
of running a ponzi scheme in variety
actually took back the statement
what but here's the details okay okay
so the allegations
that his former partner who claims he
was running a ponzi scheme
were made under oath okay okay
sounds serious but the ex-partners
claims
not under oath once they settled
he took it back and he said he didn't
even mean to file the lawsuit
so once they settled he not
under oath said oh it was just a joke
lol i didn't even mean to follow the
lawsuit
under oath his ex-partner said this
guy's running a ponzi scheme
got it so just to be clear is rewind
time
when he was speaking in a courtroom
under the threat of perjury well i don't
know if he was in court but i think he
signed something under oath verifying
that what he wrote in the lawsuit was
true and correct right
and and that the punishment for for
perjuring yourself
it's under oath is very serious yes yes
yes
so he would probably take that seriously
whereas any statement that you make
while not under oath
um you can say anything you can really
say anything
why and so after they settled
right his ex partner not under oath said
um he didn't run a ponzi scheme and i
didn't even mean to file the lawsuit
which by the way was a huge complaint
they spent a lot of money on
and so i don't really know of any lawyer
that accidentally files a complaint
and by the way the ex-partner used to
really oops i turned in the wrong paper
oh my god
oh my god i accidentally wrote up this
huge complaint oh and accidentally filed
how'd that happen
and apparently his apparently his his
ex-partner who
accused him of running a ponzi schemes
had a really prestigious law firm
and they sounds like a thing that they
would a kind of mistake that they would
certainly uh make it just accidentally
turning in like a
100-page complaint oh yeah lots of time
lots of research lots of effort
you know they accidentally wrote it
apparently too
so i guess you all need to decide for
yourself which version you think is true
the one under perjury under risk of
perjury under oath
right or the claim
after they settled of lol we didn't mean
to file it just kidding
hmm so that's my disclaimer okay
okay are we clear yeah that was clear
all right thank you oh uh update from ab
um also buying fake followers is against
instagram's terms of service not only
can they purge the fake followers but
they also reserve the right to suspend
accounts that become
involved in this practice now
right they're not fake they're not fake
they're real i would say they're
ill-gotten yeah i think that that's how
companies like that can get around it by
structuring it as a giveaway yada yada
well can i give you a general condition
from instagram go ahead please we
reserve the right to modify or terminate
the instagram
service for any reason without notice at
any time yeah i would nominate ryan
cavanaugh for deletion
i'm just that's scary these are
ill-gotten followers right
i guess i did something to piss off the
instagram god
because usually someone follows you on
instagram because they at least know who
you are or care about you at least a
little bit sure
but if you're following just for free
[ __ ] and you're following 99 people and
one of which is ryan kavanagh you never
heard of the guy
that's an ill-gotten follower i think
they should erase his account
hmm just watching my algorithms get
crushed because that's not
insane instagram is a place where we
come to interact
to you know to get invested to care i
mean i'm not on there to follow
just a bunch of people and nobody cares
i mean that's what ryan kavanaugh is
doing
not allegedly end minecraft
anyway peace and love
all right we're like an hour into the
episode and uh we should probably tell
you something it is the ryan kavanaugh
accused by ex-partner of running a ponzi
scheme podcast right
yeah yeah that's true that's true anyway
having too much fun
um we're gonna have coffeezilla call in
a little bit
super interesting great guy who's been
running all these investigations on
these crypto scams
and i want to tee him up a little bit
before we get him on the phone here
um logan paul friend of the show
good friend of the show logan paul
i have known everybody he's doing this
whole big thing like he reformed like he
changed his ways
i feel like you even fell for it a
little bit because i know you're about
to say that
there was a time a little while ago
where you were
you're respecting his hustle and and
what he was doing with the
with impulsive and stuff and i i well
you know what i will
say i invited my time i was like i will
say about logan paul
you first of all you can't chris says
guys hustle i mean i don't think he's a
good dude i think he's a shitty dude and
i think he's cutting corners all the way
like pokemon cards
and the box the boxing and the podcast i
mean he hustles i'm amazed at the
space he continues to carve out to make
money sure
let me tell you about it he was a path
blazer with the merch too back in the
day so these guys are very money
oriented and they know how to do it
and that's where i think he gets into
trouble here that doesn't mean i don't
think he's a shitty guy i mean he
so with all the crypto scams going away
who not who's not getting involved in it
logan paul is getting involved in it um
and this is a great one because there's
so much evidence of deception on his
part
uh it's this new doge style crypto
called
dink doink and logan was pretending to
be an
unaffiliated third-party investor
acting as if dink doink is just some
random meme coin
uh he stumbled upon which we will prove
uh conclusively that he was actually one
of the founders of this coin
he just tweets out this is from june
28th not that long ago actually [ __ ]
that was like a few weeks ago what the
[ __ ]
he says this is the dumbest most
ridiculous [ __ ] coin i've ever seen
and that's why i'm all in i've never
heard of
this coin i have no idea what's going on
with this coin
i don't know anything about this coin
i'm all in i think when i think about
nothing happens
trying to think but nothing happens
let's watch this what is dink doink
so they rip off south park which is just
a nightmare
deep don't get my favorite coin want you
to dink on my face
take a drink on my chest yeah yeah dink
don't think you're my favorite card
why don't you come on over take pictures
of my feet yeah
yeah think doink you're my favorite coin
why don't you take my little sister to
the prom don't donker please
such a [ __ ] nightmare they're trying
to be south park
how it is how do they get isn't i i
would think that south park would have
some pro
i guess not because it's like it's just
an art style yeah
i mean i don't know but they're
obviously using the likeness of
southpark characters to garner some kind
of trust right off the gate
very manipulative yeah danton you're my
favorite scam pretend
logan paul doesn't
[Music]
and lives in a van outside the team 10
house
i'm a [ __ ] savage you got to do it
i'd rather be
proven wrong what's the great fall line
i'd rather speak up and be wrong than be
muffled and be wrong
i'd rather speak up and be wrong
than be muffled and wrong
here hit me with a bunch of paul family
sound bites zack
is
[Music]
you know what's the sound dink doink
it's when you rub your uh
water cup on the on the uh prison cell
bars
ding dong
dink dink is a total fraud
so anyway this is the freaking bloomberg
so the point is logan's acting
and again very reminiscent of if you
guys remember the cs go scam
with uh pro syndicate and t martin
they're like i just found this website
you know acting like you're not involved
not disclosing your affiliation
is very shady so anyway here he is on
impulsive pretending like
once again pumping the coin that's why
it's called a pump and dump
or a rug pull he's now in the act of
pumping the coin he's tweeting about it
he's talking on the show
and this is the lead up to the rug bowl
which
does happen and here's logan paul in the
show talking about dink doink
dude this whole [ __ ] tribute showing
me his ding-dong thing or whatever the
[ __ ] is this
it's like a spring it's a crypto meme
coin and uh it's [ __ ]
it's hilarious it's [ __ ] hilarious it
is pretty funny
proof of fraud is right there it's not
funny it's not funny
first of all saying it's funny is fraud
it's hilarious
it's hilarious and saying it's funny is
proof that you're invested because
nobody
would literally go on the record and say
this is funny it'd be way too damaging
to their reputation
that's cutest [ __ ] i've ever seen and i
mean because
if you don't know about crypto [ __ ]
coins like most of them don't have
utility
and so you know the dink doing people
have just
leaned into how [ __ ] dumb this [ __ ]
is and people love it like
it's just fun and it's cartoons loves it
logan in south park style
who loves it who loves dink think name
one
it's just fun it's just fun this this
coin this coin is fun i mean what's he
even talking about what's fun about it
in his defense i'm sure it's very fun
for him yeah yeah yeah
for him yeah of dollars the fbi asked
what he knew about it
right then it got done fun that's why
it's called a dink point
a dink fun doink not fun every guy
i'm a dink doink fan it's the dumbest
[ __ ] i ever seen and that's why i'm all
in
hey logan why don't you tell him you
actually designed the [ __ ] dumbass
spring
he's all in they're all uh lying by the
way look how his friend
so logan designs this whole [ __ ]
tribute show me you know but they're all
in on it watch this don't think door
they're rid of the [ __ ]
thing it's like a spring it's a crypto
yeah yeah you all know logan's the one
that drew that spring
he stole it from simpsons too we'll get
into i'm getting ahead of myself
you guys ready for all these dumbass
cartoons
i ready this is their website
if you're watching this video you're
probably thinking to yourself
what the heck is dink doing and that's a
really good question
at first glance oh this is good you guys
just in case you're
afraid of missing out the max supply is
10
quad trillion dink doinks
there's 10 quatrillion
[Music]
created by some of the world's top
comedians and influencers
but dink doing is so much more than that
dink doing is the world's first ever
decentralized ip given to a community
and run by a community
in the past ivy like mickey mouse or
family guy
is owned by a centralized entity that
centralized
entity operates under strict guidelines
stop it
[Music]
just stop
here's dink dunk on social media ding
dong you're my favorite coin
oh i think we watched that already yeah
that's the south park thing
uh here you know the spring although by
the way but before we get into it
is a clean rip-off
of homer simpson and when you're olympic
hello first springy
when you're stealing ideas from homer
simpson
right who's kind of like you know the
dumbass
then what does that make you exactly i'm
trying to think but nothing happens
seth macfarlane no i he's family guys
i'm sorry cease and desist
anyway after logan paul pumped it up
y'all guess what happened oh big massive
dumpster it exponentially rose and
everybody who got invested
is an overnight millionaire here is his
weight here is his impulsive and then
daddy's
what somebody said daddy's about to get
his beak wet i'm about to get his dink
doinked
my favorite coin i watch the value
plummet
and lose all my assets think doink is
what i think of my fans
i just scam them and steal the money
come on everybody
dig dog gp coming at ya
i like young girls and my songs feed
them to
me i don't care about my fans
i just steal their money as the source
of a crypto scheme
thank you i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta
do it
thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
here's the paul impulsive whole goon
squad pretending like
we don't know what dink doink is we just
love it
this is so fun it's just fun what up
dink doing telegram
it's me logan paul now i know what
you're thinking
look what the [ __ ] are you doing here
i'm doing the same thing as you holding
my doink
that's what i'm doing logan what are you
doing here well this is a [ __ ] coin i
believe in
it's my favorite one to be honest think
doing is so much more than a meme coin
it's a multimedia coin
cartoon meets crypto it's the blockchain
baby
in in in cartoons a lot of people tell
me
look and paul what are you doing here
well the truth is i actually founded
this coin and i'm being deceptive and
acting like
i just found out about this just like
you guys
is this the narrower like this
give me that godfather oh god you're
right on we went over this
damn donk you're my favorite
coin and now what is this i founded
logan paul as one of the owners
one of the founders he drew the spring
itself
you come to me pitching me dick doing
dink donk logan paul
who you texting i'm just browsing
twitter
you just browse twitter when i do the
godfather
[Music]
you lied to me logan paul
you told me dink doink was your favorite
chick when you didn't tell me you owned
the [ __ ] coin i know it was you
freedom
and now i gotta take you on a roll boat
out back on the lake
[Music]
and give you a little bit of that dink
dunk love you broke my heart
my heart
i thought we were part of the
organization the pole family
all i wanted was to pitch a camper
outside your house and get
and for you to hook me up with all your
young female friends
not necessarily saying under the age of
18 but close
like right on the border of being legal
and not i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta
do it
it's not statutory rape but it's as
close as you could possibly get
that's all i wanted from you logan paul
and now i find out you're the owner of
dingtong
you broke my heart
i know my heart i know it was you logan
thank you stop it's not my fault he went
to this weird ass de niro impression
what am i supposed to do it's a
blockchain baby in in
in cartoon fun comedy format i'm gonna
be doing an episode myself soon
and as a holder and think going i
believe in this [ __ ] i think it's yeah
so this is the fake narrative
so as you guys will find out he was
there since the beginning
and it's likely one of the f i mean he's
one of the founders and so now they did
this thing where
they planned this all out where he would
tweet it out and be like i love ding
dong
and then he was going to start they
would reach out to him and then
i'm doing cartoons now i'm part of ding
dok that was their plan from the
beginning he was involved from the very
top it's deceptive
all the way down so logan being a little
schemey
little pumpkin celebrities as well gonna
get involved in episodes doing
voiceovers fun cartoon stuff
it's [ __ ] dink throwing bro and i'm
ready to start sucking some dink i'll
see y'all soon okay
you like that one zach
mike magilic the paragon of uh
maturity intelligence
and totally over the table
nothing shady going on here mike
magelick
right hey guys what's up the sweaters
are suspicious
here to send some love and camaraderie
to the
dink doing telegram team [ __ ] i know you
guys have been busting your ass to make
sure
that the hottest newest coin of 2021
is dink doink with the hottest
functionality and
all of the most built-in is it
embarrassing that mike even thinks he
can influence anything
listen lana i know you're the baddest
you're the baddest baddie
you're super wealthy independent wealthy
and i'd love to move in with you
but i have to start a content house with
faze blanks and aiden ross
so here i am this is what i chose to do
techniques
instead of settling down as almost 40
year old man tactics
and capabilities doink is cleared to be
the hottest [ __ ] coin ever
i just want to say keep up the good work
and if you guys do
everything that you're doing right now
even more exponentially
we can go to the top of this whole
[ __ ] market dude
[ __ ] yeah is he gaming here
like it and the joke is that he's a
dumbass but i mean
it's hard to distinguish him pretending
to be dumb
because that is his natural state right
and he's got [ __ ] in his gym shorts he's
got [ __ ] in his gym shorts his hoodie
says suspicious i think we should take
a call for help seriously suspicious
he allegedly has [ __ ] in his gym shorts
he's an assist does he have [ __ ] in his
gym shorts or allegedly
well zach is the one who alleged it i'm
just trying to help you out a little bit
sure let's go with the legend no he does
i'm here to confirm all this [ __ ]
oh you know yeah you know for a fact i
know let's say right now i'm here today
ethan and i were working out at a
24-hour fitness
and um okay calm down i'm not giving
real anecdotes you're going too far
very specific and actionable zach yeah
zach's like i'm gonna give the
prosecution what they need the 24-hour
fitness was in minecraft
in minecraft yes but yes he does anyway
mike pretending mike uh pretending to be
a dumbass that doesn't know anything
about crypto
for once he's being honest
his friend mamba
also gets involved in dink doink
incidentally how is it that
everyone in his orbit is supporting this
coin
odd what
the [ __ ] is up don't telegram
evan aka dwarf mama here to tell you
each and every one of you is beautiful
you know why you know why
because y'all are part of one of the
greatest
if not the greatest [ __ ] coin of all
time
of all time dink doing this is so
embarrassing
it's hard to watch to be honest with you
brutal but they're trying so hard to
commit fraud and i just don't understand
it's like logan has enough money why is
he doing this
did he get like [ __ ] 10 20 million
dollars for yeah
they say 20 million and he's like you
know what i should do now that i have 10
to 20 million dollars in the bank
commit fraud give me fraud for probably
like
a tenth of that amount of money yeah if
that
yeah i would say i would say that's
accurate [ __ ]
moon you don't believe me wait hold on
ding dong's going to the moon
splash cut once again to the chart
we believe in ding dong ding dongs going
to the mood
after they tweet and post all of this
where's the moon which direction would
the moon be it would be like up here
oh right yeah generally though the moon
would be up
referring to right yes dink doink
went um down which is the opposite
direction of the moon i think
big massive dumps yeah
um so hmm
guess they were proven wrong an innocent
mistake
you don't have to you can just be naive
and dumb
it's all good but y'all
the community is telegram community
we're not naive we're not dumb
we're [ __ ] family a little too meta
we're gonna go
we family we're family and we're going
to the moon and we're not naive and dumb
which way is the moon the moon is up
because this chart clearly shows it
going sharply down
maybe it's like the moon from majora's
mask it's just going down i guess if
you're on mars
right what if the moon comes to you
right exactly yeah
or or perhaps you know in in a
general relativity you know there is no
directional bias like up
down it's all your frame of reference so
i mean it's not he's not so i'm just
trying to give him the benefit of the
doubt when he says going to the moon
if we're like i'm just trying to help
him in court he could say well your
honor up
you know to the moon is a subjective uh
directional force
yeah it could be down like it depends
where you are on the earth sometimes the
moon is below you
right if if the moon's on the opposite
side of the planet then
logan paul like a flat earther for a
little bit i think that was a gag
yeah maybe maybe i mean he's i don't
know he doesn't understand how the moon
were
yeah so that makes sense yeah he's
talking he when he says moon he's
talking relative
to you know where your place on earth is
and if the moon is which moves
no that's not true the moon is actually
specifically the earth satellite so i'm
gonna have to correct you there dan
uh if you want to get technical you
would refer to it as luna
no it's called a satellite dance uh no a
moon can be any
orbiting body around a planet uh within
uh
the solar system no it's not a moon is a
satellite
first of all the moon is the name of our
satellite
a satellite is a body that or is a large
body that orbits a planet uh
colloquially
uh you may refer to our moon as the moon
but technically it would be
referred to as a luna oh [ __ ] oh you're
just saying technically but it
technically
a moon is called a satellite if you go
to another planet
it wouldn't be called a moon it would be
called a satellite
the moon is the name of our satellite
dam i know that check it yeah that's
incorrect
no uh you're incorrect other planets
have moons the moon is not just
referring to armor
the name of our satellite is the moon a
satellite is an object that moves around
a larger area
the definition of the satellite for it i
mean the moon define
do they the natural satellite of earth
the natural satellite of earth i know i
know i know
visible chiefly at night by reflecting
light from the sun
okay i'll take my apology dan
you're wrong other other satellites
natural satellite of earth yeah i get it
i know i was
i was i was being uh no you were trying
to come
at me and some [ __ ] yeah i don't know
but i'm confident on my moon knowledge
good [ __ ]
like the episode the office where
michael scott's the new smart guy after
he outsmarts oscar in an argument the
audience will understand
all about china what is a moon simple
definition a large round object that
circles the earth
boom moon [ __ ] moon
they call that the the moons of uh
jupiter they have a game galilean
galilean moon
yeah i know and so does our moon it's
called the moon it's called
the moon sorry sorry i'm sorry
thank you i think you guys are both
right no
don't stop it baby get out sorry don't
sit on the fence on this one
what happened to being the simp you're
right dan sorry
sorry what is that damn don't bite your
hand at fiji dan
oh thank you for apologizing damn sorry
exactly
sorry thank you for apologizing dan it's
meaningful to me i know i get a lot
wrong
but on this one it'd be nice to get an
argument that i was finally ready
yeah yeah yeah i was just i was trying
to do a bit and then i got way too
serious
all right exact story my life zach
apollo
have dan apologized to me one more time
zach sorry thank you that's very
meaningful
sorry very meaningful thank you
it feels sorry it feels good thank you
just take it in uh dink doink and mike
are hanging out this is interesting
oh here's mike hanging out with dink
doing wow a
mega influencer like that oh
they're chilling and so the spring is it
is called dink doy yes because so what
so both the spring the spring itself is
dink doing yes
but then the coin is called dink twink
the coin is the spring
that's clearly a spring not a coin right
that i'll agree on what was that
sniffling noise you were doing
who dan who was doing the bit he was
doing this like
oh he's doing another looks like just
being a nerd
wow okay anyway so here's the big twist
here's the big twist okay here's the
dink doink
ceo on a podcast giving up the whole
[ __ ] game
whoops and i went me and i
i live with logan paul i i have for a
long time the ceo
lives with logan paul
well that's how he heard about it right
they were at the kitchen table
you know having breakfast and he was
like yo i'm i just heard of this dink
doink
coin
at my kitchen counter yeah i think but
nothing happens
man i can't believe he [ __ ] up this
bad and gave away the game here listen
to this i went me and i i live with
logan paul
i have for a long time and i went
through this whole
crypto experience with logan he's my
best friend
to be to be honest with you stephen we
might as well you know
be be honest about how this came about i
was chilling with logan
and and we were like what's the
stupidest name we could think of
for like a coin right what's the
weirdest name we could think of for like
what's with the music dude everything
about what's on screen here
is [ __ ] cracking me up the guy
couldn't have [ __ ] logan moore
what is this
a picture of some dude and some
vaporwave playing and who doesn't want
to just listen to music during a
conversation
but he couldn't give up the game more he
says i live with logan
he's my best friend we've did this
together
from day one he came up with the name
didn't he just say that logan came up
with the name
yes huh that's fantastic i just heard it
i heard about this
mascot that's like a dumb spray we're
like dink joint oh my god his name's
dink doink
and it just came alive like logan
designed the
gta story logan defined the character
logan designed the character on his
phone
that i'll believe based off of the
character's design
which by the way he's stole from homer
simpson right even original in the
slightest bit
yeah um
a case closed what the [ __ ] yeah i mean
unless that guy's
lying i guess i mean why would he lie he
says he lives with them and they're best
friends
how do you lie about something like that
i agree it seems like a stretch
hey now is this guy why is he the dink
or is he the doink
uh we already explained that the spring
is the
uh dink and the doink okay maybe well
doink means fool
so just put that out there i don't know
about doink meant like uh
like i want i don't think they're
worried about definitions
now here he is this is fantastic in case
you guys are wondering the the main poll
of this coin
well this is the ceo that happens to
live with logan paul
and here he is the this podcast host
says
why should people believe in ding dong
well here's a really
fantastic answer that is so compelling i
myself
am ready to invest in this coin even
though it's dead
so good you know as you well know
there's over 10
000 uh cryptos out there right now uh
what makes your project different from
the
um countless amounts of bses that launch
every day
what a great question what a great
question thanks
for that question thank you for that
like the most important question right
i've never been asked that question this
is actually my first podcast
okay as dingdong's eel so
i have a really good answer to it all
right okay let's hear it
i'm i'm i'm doing this for for
a very specific purpose and think doink
on its face is a funny cartoon and it's
a meme
um it's a community having fun on
twitter
and it's social media stars tweeting
about it every week
and you know that's what it is on its
face that's what you'll see it do
um but really to me i look at
you know you brought up bitcoin earlier
and and what's going on with elon
and those two communities now
in sort of a coral and i i find the
crypto space in this moment to be
at its most important moment it's ever
had where
such a coherent answer turns into so
passionate need at some point to move
forward
we have the technology we have the
attention we have the passion
we have everything except
a unified community
do you think he thought he nailed that i
mean that was such
incoherent stunning drivel that was
absolute dog [ __ ] that was the dumbest
[ __ ] thing i've heard a human being
utter
that's such a fantastic question i mean
i'm so glad you asked that
never been asked that i mean i'm so
important you know just so
thrilled that you asked me that question
uh you know thank you by the way
so dink doink is definitely going to the
moon yeah
after hearing that wherever the moon
after that pitch
yeah huge so here's another oh so here's
a little edit we made of
logan pretending he doesn't know what
dink doink is
combined with his partner um exposing
him for being one of the founders
enjoy it dude this whole [ __ ] tribute
show me his ding-dong thing or whatever
the [ __ ] is thinking
it's like a spring it's a crypto meme
coin and uh it's [ __ ] it's hilarious
it's [ __ ] hilarious it is pretty
funny it's the dumbest cutest [ __ ] i've
ever seen
and you know the dink doing people have
just
deleted he's the ding dong people i know
he's the dink doing it's so good too
talking about the thing that you made up
as being the funniest thing ever is the
funniest thing ever it's the cutest
thing ever
i made it on my phone in two seconds to
rip off my fans it's so
how [ __ ] dumb this [ __ ] is and people
love it like it's just fun and it's
cartoons
in south park style i'm a ding dong fan
to be to be honest with you stephen we
might as well you know
be be honest about how this came about i
was chilling with logan
and and we were like what's the
stupidest name we could think of
for like a coin right what's the
weirdest name we could
think of for like a little mascot that's
like a
dumb spray we're like dink joint oh my
god his name's dink doink
and it just came alive like logan design
that is not i was extreme game that is
so
funny yeah this is so funny
yep so there you have it
[Music]
i'm just chilling in cedar rapids oh is
hillary
invested in the dink doing here's the
ceo by the way this is the genius who
just
explained why dink doink stands out
so my official statement as the ceo on a
very important meme coin
i guess everyone wants to know what's up
with dink doing everyone
who better to tell you than the ceo
himself
is it a scam are you in logan's house
right now
he is he's in logan paul's house right
now apparently his house
right it's one in the same bro
flat out no logan wait hold on hold on
as he's explaining that it's not a scam
let me just
pull up the chart
this should be good so go ahead uh go
ahead
wherever you are um he was saying it's
not a scam so
let's let him continue here's the chart
by the way coffeezilla
that's one that tweeted that out so go
ahead uh
as you were saying yeah
is it a scam no no no flat out
no logan hasn't sold a single coin
neither has the dev team what about this
we're here to make a funny meme coin
it's a [ __ ] cartoon and if you don't
get the joke
you are the joke i don't care about
youtubers
making fake videos to lie about us to
make money i don't give a [ __ ]
we're a funny meme coin we're going to
continue to make funny cartoons
and it's that simple
i guess everyone wants to funny because
that his answer he gave to the podcast
host was very different
he was like on surface value with memes
and stuff but
underneath it's so much bigger
let the conversation begin
can you explain logan paul's affiliation
with dink doink i think that's what
people are more concerned about
oh what a piece of [ __ ] these people are
man they're [ __ ] horrible people like
just [ __ ] horrible and they're so bad
at being scammers
yeah i know the the blockchain just
gives them away i mean
they could just make a billion wallets
and never be traced back but they're
just not smart
well his [ __ ] best friend went on a
podcast and put the whole damn game out
there
anyway we're going to have coffee zilla
on he's the guy that's been running
all the investigations on logan that was
his tweet with the chart
and all of these crypto scams going on i
thought it'd be fantastic to
to talk to him to unpack some of this
stuff so let's throw it the coffeezilla
uh we have with us on zoom coffeezilla
the internet's detective who's been
looking deeply into all these crypto
scams going on
with the faze clan yes round of applause
for coffee
uh faze clan logan paul sam pepper are
these the biggest offenders that you've
found did these games check the box for
you or what are we looking at
uh yeah especially considering their
influence right because
a big part of it for me is when you're
pushing your
fans into a crypto coin or something
like that the bigger the influence you
have the more egregious
it seems so when you're gonna jump in a
coin and you know
as someone as big as logan paul i just
thought he made enough money on the
fight
like why why is he doing this doesn't
make any sense to me why are you pushing
your fans into this
that's the thing that just really pissed
me off about when i found about this
dink doing thing that logan paul is
doing
it's like he's worked so hard to repair
his image
i still think he's a douche but he's got
a little smarter about it
but then he goes into this whole dink
doink thing he's already made a ton of
money from all the [ __ ] he's been doing
it's like and then to lie about it and
mislead
so logan paul has been doing this thing
you maybe you can uh
uh set it up but logan paul started this
crypto called dink doing he acts like he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] it is
and then meanwhile the programmer went
on a podcast and was like oh yeah i made
it with logan paul and logan even made
the
logo yeah he goes he tells his fans that
um
you know i'm all in this [ __ ] coin i
just like like he just found it like
just off the street like he was just
looking around and he found and he goes
i'm all in on it
and it turns out that the founder jacob
roydo goes on a call and he goes yeah
me and logan were just looking at how
much money people were making with doge
and we decided let's make dink doink and
we said think doink and logan designed
it on snapchat and
there it was and then he promoted it to
all of his fans it makes no sense and
i agree with you he's done a lot to
repair his reputation i think he's done
a good job
of repairing it with a lot of people so
it makes no sense
i wonder if they even know what they're
doing is illegal you know what i mean
because he's like oh dogecoin just some
dumb [ __ ] thing but you've got to
know it's fraud
it's like what t martin pro syndicate
did with the cs go
gambling [ __ ] if you remember they go oh
i just found this website that i had
by the way that i own i'm not going to
tell you then i'm getting it's like you
it's it's very misleading and probably
illegal
to say i just found this random website
you have to disclose your affiliations
especially when you're in that level of
influence and you're promoting something
and we still don't know
did logan get paid and how much did he
get paid to promote i mean
i didn't see a disclaimer maybe like
when i see not financial advice that
doesn't mean this
fit this is sponsored right right that's
different from saying that so how can
they get away with this
i think so look i don't know who
i'm not gonna sit i'm not gonna make any
guesses but i think
someone will eventually go down for
something like this whether it be
k or whether it be logan or somebody
yeah the stuff i've seen against k makes
me think he's going to go to jail
um it's sad look i don't even know that
he's like the mastermind behind all this
but he's
done it in the worst possible way
i've been constantly just reaching out
in good faith trying to talk to
everybody involved i've talked to banks
i've reached out to jarvis i've reached
out to
summer rae like a lot of these people
won't talk to me but i reached out to
everyone involved and i just said like
look we need to talk and then if i have
something bad against them i'll say look
here's what i have you have anything
anything to say and their lawyer comes
back
sends me a cease and desist letter and
says that's extortion
that's called reporting that's called
fair reporting
it doesn't make any sense well asking
for comment is a good
is an act of good faith isn't it it's
like the opposite of extortion
look i've been at first i had to get
2k through banks because at first banks
was the only one talking banks was like
look dude face has nothing to do with it
blah blah blah
nobody else was talking banks was the
only one talking saying
faze wasn't involved and at this point i
don't think he knew about save the kids
i'm comfortable saying that i don't
think banks knew
but there are some other players
involved like like jordan galen
who was a senior talent member uh
manager at faze
you know about him yeah i watched your
video i learned about him from that
he was running deals uh you got k i mean
you've just got
like a huge number of phase people so it
is a massive slip up
to like have all your talent running
around doing crypto deals
so at the end of the day what you have
here
is a ton of influencers you know
to put it simply st i mean
stealing money from their fans their man
their fans are putting money into this
pool
thinking they're investing and the
creators are pulling it right back out
so do you know if
there's any higher authority report uh
investigating into this crime currently
uh can't say too much on that just
disclose it but i would
i would guess yeah there's a good chance
there's a good chance that people
are investigating this um but
look let me say this i think a big thing
is did they sell or not like in the case
of logan
we don't know how much or if he got paid
i would guess he got paid but we don't
know if he got paid in doing it we don't
know if he's sold
right we can makes we can speculate but
in the case of
kay we have his wallet we
know that after being an ambassador for
a charity coin
called save the kids which is just the
worst possible so
that's a highway to the feds i mean i
gotta admit
um but we know that he sold him 24 hours
and so
that's that's where it crosses that line
for me it's like once we know you sold
right and then i was uh mudohar put out
a video recently where he got
went in depth into the cryptos and when
you look at these guys
it's like they get paid and then they
sell immediately
and you see it all the time they promote
these coins uh they get paid
they sell immediately you know well no
and they were running
giveaways specifically running giveaways
and then he was giving the money to
wallets connected to him not only that
but it happened on three separate
giveaways right
where it was the same winner yeah no no
he gave several like
we cross checked all the winners and
several of them won
every single giveaway eclipse that's
illegal coin
that's from safe galaxy that is a huge
fraud
you're saying it i mean like i right now
i have a big fat cease and desist letter
um
sitting right next to me right over here
i'll say it's fraud uh they can get in
line i'm already being sued
that sounds like fraud to me well ja
rule what do you think that is
that's not fraud ja rule doesn't think
it's fraud what would you call it y'all
roll
that uh false advertising false
advertising
that i i would guess yeah i could say
that
they need to get job roll on the board
of ding donk and uh
he got to get y'all rolling face he's
the only one can dig their way out of
this
but you know um yeah so so they're doing
these giveaways
the winner is the manager right
you guys have proof there's sev there's
several winners i believe
in the case of you'll have to refer to
mudahar's video because i'm just going
off memory right now
but one of the winners of one of those
giveaways was
um was jordan galen
like that man it's insane then he
immediately sells it once he gets it
right
yeah these guys are selling right away
man did you see the uh
aiden raw stuff oh yeah i've been fought
i can't believe they didn't
i don't know why people let adam ross
get away with so much [ __ ] because he
just straight up said
the milf token was a scam i hope none of
you guys bought that [ __ ]
well guess who gave him that deal the
same guy
jordan galen and jordan galen got a
bunch of milf token right before aiden
ross did that deal
dumped his bags right away made
thousands of dollars
i mean i i haven't so i watched
mudahar's video
you can see on the blockchain how much
actually aiden ross got paid for that
he got paid like close to 200 000 for
that brief
[ __ ] milf token crazy
so of course he's like yeah [ __ ] my fans
you know stupid dude i just i got paid a
bag i hope nobody
you got to pull up that clip like he
goes he goes yeah i hope nobody actually
got that thing someone sent me on
discord because like
it's pretty incredible that you can just
blatantly say to your fans i don't care
about you
i'm you literally using you i'm using
not only using it
i am i am to your detriment
getting money from you and
somehow it's just cool because they all
they just think that's not a problem i
don't know how that's possible
i don't get it because someone he's
going to say he's going to say i didn't
know milf token
um was a sketchy coin he already well
here he is
admitting to such here i'll pull it up i
don't know if you can see it but you'll
probably be able to hear it
ig number one for stock tips aiden must
buy amc
got that nice gucci uh chat by the way
that milf token [ __ ] i did a while back
i already told you guys don't buy that
[ __ ] i got paid a bag do that [ __ ]
like i don't give a [ __ ] i hope none of
you guys actually bought it
sounds like he knows it's a scam it does
it does sound a lot like because let's
let's examine let's closely examine what
he's saying here aiden must buy amc
today
i can't get over what a [ __ ] his
bedroom is this guy who's apparently
getting paid so much money
living in this content house with
facebook this guy's probably a
multi-millionaire oh yes
i'm sure he is you don't do you know how
much money he gets from the gambling
have you looked into that [ __ ]
uh yeah no it's well he was talking i
don't know if it's the
house or if it's him but they're paying
him
somewhere above two million dollars a
month yeah that's the because
was that to him specifically because
somebody another gambling site offered
him two million and he said no i have a
better deal
yeah that's to him that's to him two
million a month
and he lives like he's [ __ ] still
with his parents
so there you go by the way that milk
token [ __ ] i did while back
i already told you guys don't buy that
[ __ ] i got paid a bag do that [ __ ]
so why do you think he would tell his
fans don't buy it
what would possibly be the explanation
for that
i mean i think he knew it's not going to
go well for his fans if they bought it
right but he wanted to make the bag dude
yes it's all and we know
what's up with this new culture of like
it's all about the bag if i have
money you got that money that's why i
put this back here dude so i could get
credibility with all these guys i got
the lambo in the back because i know
that's all they believe in it's just
clout chasing
yeah show me how to what's that money
what's the what's the um
the horsepower on that thing oh dude let
me show you let me show you just
oh it is anti-gravity
dude nobody's got this see that what
point did you promote to get that man
you want that tits coin or what
yeah dude i'm on that um elon sperm
token yeah
yeah i heard elon sperm is going to the
mars
um so don't actually buy that coin guys
please
don't buy any coin stop no more coins
[Applause]
it's ridiculous so um
like i don't give a [ __ ] how many guys
actually bought it
yeah it's all about his bag what about
the bags of his [ __ ] audience
not i mean who cares dude i got the
money i got the bag
got out well anyway you know you and uh
mudohar aka some ordinary gamer you are
on the coffeezilla channel you guys have
been doing a lot of leg work here to
bring this stuff to life
and it really is important because you
know between this and the
gambling that i've been witnessing on
twitch
it's just a really low point i think an
influencer
uh in history and when you have people
like logan paul
like i don't expect much from faze clan
like these guys have always been
scumbags
but when you look at like i mean logan
paul's i've always thought was a piece
of [ __ ]
but like dude when you're him behind
he's a huge influencer right one of the
biggest now
and when he you have someone like that
who's you know
doing this dink doing [ __ ] it's just
it's just bad for everybody any legal
it's just it's a low point
it's a [ __ ] horrible low point
it is did you see the cartoon though
with logan in it of course
it is the biggest embarrassment i'd be
embarrassed to be associated with the
cartoon
much less the crypto coin well you know
i think mudahar made the best point he
says
when lo here's how you know that logan
paul is committing fraud
okay you ready for this he says in his
video promoting dink doink
that they're funny cartoons
these cartoons are not funny and no
self-respecting person would ever claim
them to be funny
the only way you would ever claim these
cartoons are funny is if you had a
vested
interest in this dink toink therefore
irrefutable evidence
that he is committing fraud thank you
get in line for suing me
yeah unlike you i'm a comedian not a
journalist so i have a little more
leeway
there you go anyway i'm looking forward
to
coffeezilla on youtube there's a lot
more to come right for
with your investigation a lot more to
come
um i just found out about something
today that blew my mind and
i can't i can't believe these guys are
getting away with it it's this i'll just
be honest
it's the it's this la la vegas there's
this big circle of like guys
that are seem to consistently come up in
this
over and over and over again and i'm
determined to get to the bottom of it so
we'll see i'm trying to dig up i just
found out who manny
is i found out who a bunch of people are
i'm talking to everybody involved so
hopefully we find out who the mastermind
is
you know these are the same people that
were involved in you know the cs go
gambling [ __ ] back in the day it's just
they make money at any cost they don't
care
they're scammers they're scammers at
heart and they don't give a [ __ ]
the problem is they don't know when to
stop i mean they have legitimate money
but it's never enough
especially when you look at someone like
logan paul scumbag i think
yeah i think it's important to say real
quick is like there were people who were
involved who didn't know like you look
at tico
i don't know if you saw that like this
guy faced tico he got involved
the kid helped put in 35 000 of his own
money
or somewhere around that and then bought
in into the coin because he thought it
was going to actually save the world or
whatever save the kids
he never sold so he's down he's out
35k so it's pretty clear not everyone
knew the same amount so i think it's
really clear when we like careful we
have to be careful when we go into these
fraud situations or scam situations that
we
deal out you know the hey your scam
whatever
like according to what they actually did
because in the case of people like tico
even um nikon only sold like a third and
then he held on he bought
what it's complicated that's all i'm
going to say all right
fair enough absolutely coffee's ill on
youtube
everybody tune in this is going to be a
juicy bumpy ride so i will be watching
and hopefully everyone else too thanks
for calling it sharing your story i
appreciate that take care
well guys um i had fun today
we learned a lot we had some fun i made
a very important retraction about or not
retract i wouldn't say retraction but i
made i'm not not a retraction i retract
nothing what i did say about ryan
cavanaugh
very important distinction well is that
ryan
he's the one on the left oh that's ryan
yeah that's that's ryan it's hard to
tell
they really look so similar
ryan's this one from the variety article
over here ian
there accused by ex-partner
of running a ponzi scheme
which we've now clarified was under oath
that oh yeah so so i just this is a
really important
clarification i want to make for the
record right his partner
said under oath that ryan kavanagh
was running a ponzi scheme no
he did not he then he went on to say not
under oath
that the big complaint he filed was
filed accidentally right
and ryan is not running a ponzi scheme
and the timeline on this just to be
clear was after
they settled settled yes which you know
do we know what that settlement was
no we haven't we couldn't possibly know
but like i mean
one possible i'm not saying it's
possible that in a settlement
that could be part of the arrangement
right also obviously i have no idea
mm-hmm but if ryan gave him a big payout
and said hey
you know just say that you meant to
accidentally file it
right that would be that that could be a
possible scenario possible
that's definitely a plausible scenario
so you guys decide
i'm just being out here for the sake of
clarity and honesty so you guys decide
if ryan kevin if ryan's ex-partners
accusation against him running a ponzi
scheme under oath is true
or when he later retracted it
not under oath after a settlement
and said they accidentally filed a
lawsuit which was lesbians was kind of
bone-headed
prestigious law firm accidentally filing
a lawsuit just
dropped their pen and it just well
scribbled all over a page
this is him going to the judge jesus go
give me that back give me that back up
nope sorry too late
it's already been filed
you know anyway thank you for watching i
love fun today
it's the end of the episode i'm eating
pears we're having no episode on friday
right
i'm sorry there's been a lot of back and
forth but i think that's where we've
lived i think
not only myself but i think that guys
everyone here
deserves a little break everyone's been
working super hard
around the clock and
this is the only time in my life that i
think i'll get
until i die that i'll be able to
actually just
have a legitimately like a few days
with no responsibility i have no
responsibility right now which is
something i can't say i've had for a
decade
or more more than a decade and i don't
think i'll be able to say that ever
again until i die
so let's do it let's take a day off
it's friday baby yeah we won't we
deserve friday
yeah this is the first time for me
i'm gonna be watching the loki finales
what i'll be doing
everybody like i have people telling me
you gotta watch this so good and then
the same people are like uh never mind i
took it back it wasn't good
it was what take anything back i like
that show okay well that's the finale's
airing
i've heard from other people that it
went it didn't completely didn't stop i
don't know
this isn't me saying this well i'm
telling you right now stop the logie
slam
sparky's plan sorry so this is the first
time
sorry sorry thank you for the apology
dan
it it means a lot i did not apologize i
apologize for this thing it is
never back down sorry sorry anyway
i'm gonna be watching loki i'm gonna be
um dan i was thinking of doing dark
souls
a new playthrough as magic user
it's easy mode i feel like you can't
capture the magic of the game on another
playthrough i just don't know if it's
for me
oh you know it can be fun to do it again
to just challenge yourself to uh
try and do it quickly you know what i
mean now that you're not speed running
well not i mean you don't have to
be super serious about it but yeah just
see if you can scoot on through there
sorry
take out some demons and stuff apologize
dan i will never observe you guys
so every time you hit that sorry i'm
hitting the zack sound by you okay
exactly it's not the same thing though
because it's not me
saying that it's not the same thing i
actually
i think you guys might be ruining the
show here
audio-wise sorry thank you dan that's
meaningful
all right guys hope you enjoyed i had a
lot of fun i hope you guys did too
have a great weekend i'm sorry we're not
gonna be here on friday but you know
what
i'm gonna miss you guys we'll be back
next week we're just going to take a
little break the guys deserve it
and uh and we're just going to enjoy
weekend have a fantastic weekend it's
friday maybe
on friday obviously and um
we'll see you next week so think of us
keep us in your thoughts and prayers and
we'll do the same for you okay
bye appreciate you sorry